مع الان دكتور يحيى مكه طبيب اختصاصي في
علم الفيروسات من مدينه اليوم الفرنسيه
اهلا بك دكتور يحيى ان نتوقف معك عند هذه
الموجه الجديده اذا صحت تعبير لفيروس كوبي
19 هناك حديث عن ارتفاع ولو طفيف
بالاصابات بهذا الفيروس وتحذير من الحكومه
خصوصا رئيسه الوزراء
بضروره او همم ارتداء الكمامات الوقايه في
وسائل النقل ما هو تقييمكم للوضع على
الوبائي في فرنسا
تحياتي لك واشكرك على الاستضافه
الوضع بدا يزعجون نوعا ما ويخيف السلطات
حتى لن نكون في موجه كبيره الموجه التاسعه
لكوفي وكما تعلمين سيدتي نزعنا القناع
ورفعنا كل القيود فالاحتكاك الاشخاص وخاصه
الغلق في المدارس في الحضانات في الروضات
وخاصه في كذلك في سوق الملائكه فهذه
الاحتكاك وخاصه الجو البارد الذي هو موسم
انتشار الفيروسات والفرق ما بين السنوات
الماضيه وهذا الشتاء هو انه عده فيروسات
يوميا منذ اسبوع وعدد الذين دخلوا
المستشفى
اكثر من خمس مياه مريض في العنايه المركزه
ومعظمهم لم يتلقوا اللقاح او تلقوا
امراض المزمنه وكبار
بينما الخطوره التي تكمل كذلك عندما
انتشار الفيروسات الافليفيونزا نوعين
الالف هاء ثلاثه ونون ثلاثه اشهر
وعندنا انفلونزا وعندنا فيروسات التي هي
اكثر انتشارا عند الاطفال
الذي يصيب القصبات الرئوي
الرينو فايروس فعندما كوكتيل من الفيروسات
انتشرت ولذا هذا السبب الذي ادى الى
السيده رئيسه وزراء
في وسائل النقل
طيب دكتور يحيى هناك ايضا يضاف الى هذا
المساله همم يعني مرض الذي يصيب الاطفال
خصوصا هناك دعوه من عريضه في صحيفه لموند
10,000
عامل في مجال الصحه والذين يدعونا الحكومه
الى التحرك اضافه الى هذا همم
الانفلونزا الموس هنا في فرنسا ما هي ربما
الاجراءات التي يمكن اتخاذها لتفادي
الاصابه
كذلك الوقح ضد الانفلونزا وخاصه عند
العمال في المستشفيات الاطباء الممرضين
لانه ليس الاجباري هو يعني
نشجع العمال لكن كذلك كل مواطن له الحق ان
ياخذ وخاصه كبار السن والمرضى المسلمين ان
ياخذوا التحضير انفلونزا وخاصه كذلك
المدخنين بينما للبومكيوليت السبب الكذب
توافذ الاطفال على المستشفيات ففي بعض
المناطق وبعض الولايات همم اصبحت تفوت تحت
كذلك سر جديده للاطفال لان هذه الفيروسات
اصبحت الشرسه نوعا ما لانه غيابها لمده
ثلاث سنوات
لم تكن لم تكن بها فلم تكون لنا اجسام
مضاده ضد هذه عند الاطفال حتى عندك كبار
السن فانت شعرها سبب هذا ال- ال- العدو
الكبيره والاصابات الخطيره عند الحضانه
والمدارس وحتى المعلمات والمؤهلات في
تربيه الاطفال فلذا همم ليس لنا لقاح ضد
ال- ال- البروك ونحن كمخبر رئيسي ومركزي
في فرنسا وفي اوروبا لنا الدراسه للنصر
الى اللقاح ان شاء الله بعد سنوات اربع
سنوات ثلاث سنوات ضد البروكوليت بينما
اللقاح ضد الانفلونزا عندنا لقاح جيد وهو
ضد اربع فيروسات اتش همم
لهذا الجدول علينا ان نشجع المواطنين من
خلال الشاشه الكريمه همم
كذلك بالكوفي
بالاختصاصيه في علم الفيروسات تحدثنا
مليون شكرا ج